hello everyone another lecture good
Sunday
day and hopefully you're doing better
than I am that's a good way to start
right people doing better than me well
now it doesn't take much to beat me it's
like saying you know you're taller than
a eunuch or you know a [ __ ] or
whatever you know I mean it's like well
eunuchs are usually but you know they
had all kinds of eunuchs I guess but
taller than the [ __ ] you know it
doesn't take much effort to beat a
[ __ ] last week oh you mean like one of
those that are deformed or whatever okay
normal guy but yeah sometimes you get
these very tall people sometimes very
short people we have a quite a big range
in human in the human population right
anyways today I want to talk a little
bit about irrationality and before I can
get to the subject to lead into it I
need to really cover something of what
we did last week and those are two
things really one is philosophy and
rational philosophy and that word
rational that adjective there has some
bearing on what we are going to talk
about today and the other one is quantum
mechanics whether quantum is rational
and we covered in the last two weeks
since you've been in going over a a lot
of the details of quantum mechanics so I
start with philosophy what is philosophy
we don't know what philosophy is because
no one has ever defined it in a
scientific manner the overall the vague
notions people have of what philosophy
is have to do with and here you have the
definition they have to do with wisdom
knowledge truth you know and true
an opinion knowledge has never been
defined wisdom we don't know what that
is you know wisdom sounds also like an
opinion so we don't have a very good
definition of what these words mean
especially the word philosophy and so
you know I've come up with a good
definition that I'm sure a lot of people
are not gonna like because it destroys
their religion that's the way I see it
at least people get offended when you
put a definition like that because you
kind of pin them to something and they
don't like that they they don't like to
be pinned you know it's like putting you
in a category or something people don't
like that but see you need to do that in
order to put things into a black and
white corner kind of thing people don't
like that too much but that's what I do
I like to put black and whites on and
off yes or knows and this is my version
of it I think so well it depends in
again if we would include philosophy I
mean otherwise what what is the point of
philosophy if it if it's not rational if
it's not under science if we're not
gonna do something with it you know if
we're just gonna deal with philosophy
for the hell of philosophy and just
think about anything and say oh yeah
Superman and he flies and and you know
I'd love to fly like him I mean is that
philosophy is mythology philosophy right
and again that's what I'm getting to I'm
saying like look at mythology you know
they've got Pegasus this flying horse
and you know the gods coming from Mount
Olympus and maybe fighting on one side
of the Trojan War and the other guys on
the other side I mean is that philosophy
can we really call that philosophy
already told you that's another
or you know a monologue either one yeah
concerning what is the best way to live
okay several situation so so there are
different versions of what people
understand by philosophy yeah you can
have a philosophy of life of how to live
and I think that's what the Buddha
Gautama you know he was referring to
that kind of thing like you know don't
worry about the the gods don't worry
about if you're one with the universe
it's how you're gonna live your life are
you happy get to know yourself you know
that kind of thing and and that's what
some people understand my philosophy but
then the question that I've got is what
is the purpose of philosophy do we want
to rationalize it do we want to use the
word in such a way that we refer to
something that we can you know put our
finger on that something that is has
some use some intellectual use well I'm
saying that you know philosophy all I
can do is tell you my person of it I'm
saying that philosophy is a part of
science and but then you know what role
does it play and again that chart I'll
put it up one more time here that church
pretty much puts it in the right context
I'm saying that you know you have
rational science what is rational
science right science is supposed to
explain and it's supposed to explain
rationally objectively and that means
you're in the case of physics you're
gonna have explained mechanisms and
causes you're just gonna say look my
theory is that you know rebels caused in
such in such way and this is the
mechanism you're not saying that you
believe in it you don't care if we you
know we don't care if you believe in and
we just want to understand the mechanism
now how do we have a counterpart to that
in philosophy well I'm saying philosophy
deals with concepts reasons and purpose
in other words philosophy can deal with
two aspects of science of explanations
on the one hand you have concepts you
can talk about love you can even talk
about consciousness you can talk about
like unset a minute ago you know we can
talk about
how to live you can talk about a lot of
things but I think that anyway you focus
this you have to have some kind of
explanation you can't just say look I'm
gonna give you a recommendation on how
to live because that's an opinion that's
you know this is what I suggest this is
what I proposed to you it's not it's it
doesn't explain anything per se okay
that's just saying you know live like
this and you'll be happy and that that
doesn't bode well well with science it
just says you know I've got a recipe for
you and that's where I have a problem
with that that's why I don't include
that under philosophy I'm saying you
know philosophy is supposed to serve a
purpose you want to have different
theories about history about psychology
about economics from and again from a an
abstract concept point of view right
yeah they use it to explain the best way
to live
there's the best way to live recipe well
what people really the process before is
to explain why that is the best and then
I have nobody when someone has you know
gives a recipe on how to do this yeah
and then I have no problem in a sense
but again the the recommendation part
I'm saying is not part of science that's
part of religion so belief it's an
opinion the the explanation part no
problem saying look this is the
explanation I have for why you should
live in this way or behave in that
direction or whatever and the the
recommendation we don't care about we
want the explanation of where you got
this of why you're recommending that
what's your what's your reasoning then
it's okay and I think only in that
context should that fall under science
but again I think that philosophy should
fall under science because otherwise we
have no other word to represent
those people who study concepts you know
they're not they're not dealing with
mechanisms or causes they just want to
deal Aurel objects for that matter they
want to deal with concepts they say you
know what is love or well not what is
love but you want to explain something
about love or you want to explain
something about consciousness or about
intelligence or about any concept for
that matter and that's one aspect the
other aspect again is you know reasons
and purpose like you know if you go into
history and you say well I always use
the same example maybe it's overused now
why did Napoleon go to Waterloo and one
guy says you know he went to get glory
the other guy says you know he went
there because he he wanted to died in
battle another guy says because his wife
chased him out of the house you know all
these theories and and that's what
people debate there and they say no no
your theory is wrong my theory is
Corinne that's where they fight and I
think that's where philosophy would
vibrate otherwise you know what's the
point of saying you know what's the
point of philosophy otherwise just to
have opinion about something
well I don't know I'm just saying that
what is the point of philosophy if it
doesn't explain something that's my
point
if it's if it doesn't explain it's just
air hot air that's all it is that's all
it amounts to me now if it explained
something you know you say you know
there was a reason for the French
Revolution okay for example and someone
then someone goes in there and says or
what's the reason and you explain as
they look this happened this happened
this happened that's your theory and
find you explain why something happened
then you learn something is he okay I
see I see where you're coming from with
this Janna is the same relation between
science and technology with philosophy
and Creed that's the exact okay that's
the exact comparison because science and
technology you can have technology
without knowing why what what cause how
it works yeah
you can have a Creed and live the Creed
you know he is tradition for example you
have some tradition that you do and it
just happens to work yeah lots of you
would be the science part would be
explaining why that tradition works
right and that's what I'm saying you
know I think if we're going to have
philosophy have any meaning it's got to
have some kind of explaining and by this
I mean that you've got to use your brain
now see if it hurts your brain you're
doing science if you're just gonna
describe a chair and say well a chair is
something that has four legs a backrest
and you know seat well you know that's
not very very very energetic it doesn't
do anything for me hey you can hurt your
brain but if it hurts your brain you
have to explain something what
philosophy in science the problem is
there's no use no no science has no use
correct physics either just to explain
the things that do have use correct
correct yeah we haven't read a tradition
it has used you don't know what it is
sometimes yeah but you're doing it you
know you kind of have like a general
idea but then to really go deep you know
in these when they like break down you
know some tradition or you know
Christian values and whatever they're
breaking when they're breaking it down
they're doing philosophy which is the
useless part you like you don't really
need to know why you're moving your arm
up and down yeah it's what's the why
it's the the reason the purpose then
then then you have to kind of use your
brain and for example I give another
example and that's a you know
mathematician of mathematic i'ma jiton
on stage he cuts the lady in half
you know describe everybody can describe
that yeah he took a saw cut her in half
then when the curtains closed open they
both bowed to the audience you know we
can all describe it it because it
doesn't take any mental ever you're just
regurgitating what you saw but the trick
the the science part is tell me how he
did the trick now that's where you have
to break your brain that's where you got
to try to figure out how did he do this
that's that's where science you know
roars
and I'm saying the same thing should
apply to philosophy as well as physics
and then you know on the other side we
have again your output to chart one more
time we have religion I'm saying really
it's just your opinion your believe it
doesn't have anything to do with God's
specifically it could involve gods it
may not it's irrelevant I'm saying
religion has to do with opinions and
beliefs what you believe is a religion
you know I if you believe in the Rope
hypothesis if you believe in quantum
mechanics if you believe in relativity
the belief part that's the part that's
opinion believe religion and then that's
one aspect the other aspect is that if
you have a rational explanation or
supernatural explanations for phenomenon
okay and again under supernatural you
know we have traditional religions
typically and under irrational we have
absolutely mathematical physics only
mathematical physics far as I know have
irrational theories no no we don't know
anything what do we know no means you
believe something knowledge justified
true belief that's what mr. Plato said
we he's the boss he's the father of all
philosophy 2000 years it survived all
attempts to even the Gettier problem
whatever yeah I know means that for you
for you something has been proved no but
but what do you is no things we know
what do you know but that's our list now
this the word analysis doesn't have any
importance unless it's related to an
explanation so if you say if I jump off
the balcony I will kill myself or
whatever right okay you haven't
explained anything now if you say let me
tell you why
I know yeah I know yeah I know and
that's the problem we use the word no we
use the word no like saying and and
that's why I defined it I defined the
word no when people don't like my
definition because it destroys their
religion and that's that knowledge or no
right yeah I define it as as follows
it's when you can predict the outcome of
an experiment without error and what am
I saying he gave an example right now he
said we know that if you jump off the
you know balcony 10th floor whatever
you're gonna kill yourself it turns out
you say ok let's bet on it ok so he
jumps at you 10 bucks he jumps out the
10th story or the 20th story balcony and
it turns out that just by sheer
coincidence someone puts a net out there
just by or the or it turns out the
firemen that they are are down there and
they have the net and you fall on the
net and you don't kill yourself so your
prediction need not come true because
you did not know all the factors
involved in that phenomenon you thought
you were gonna kill yourself it turns
out that you know you land it on grass
or or someone caught you or or maybe
your your trousers got stuck from a hook
as soon as you jumped and you know you
jump but you didn't kill yourself so you
know no it's not because it means that
we do not know because again knowledge
means that the way I defined it means
that you can predict exactly the outcome
of an experiment and and again I always
use another example not just a matter of
how you phrase the prediction like if I
say keep going if I jump off the 20
building barring anything that stops my
collision ah but but that's uh what do
you mean barring because that means yeah
but that gives you a loophole food yeah
but then you don't know okay
because that means you don't know but
that means you don't know all the
factors involved in
the phenomena that's about your chain it
does it's right I know I don't like that
I don't like that game no because then
I'm not gonna put my bet I'm not gonna
put my bed because because no because
you know you don't know because again
you're saying it well you're saying that
either you kill yourself it's a black or
white thing either you kill yourself or
you don't and you're saying well I'm
gonna kill myself
unless something else happened well yeah
of course
unless something of course why of course
how do you know that no no what I'm
saying is you're leaving yourself a loop
but I don't like that but I'm gonna bet
I'm not gonna bet because you know peak
no I'll die because you both know this
is true because we can say you know
which horse is gonna win and you're
saying okay horse number one instead of
number two and it turns out that I say
okay let's let's bet on it we bet on in
and as soon as horse number one which is
the one that you bet on is about to
cross the finish line I just shoot imma
kill him okay so he didn't win the other
one one and you say oh but you killed
him yeah I said I predicted that he
wasn't gonna win so the point is no the
point is that you lost the bet because
you said I know he's gonna win and I
didn't know that I was gonna shoot it I
know he's gonna win barring any well
again but then then there's mounting
this then your eyes you're pretty deaf
because it's not a prediction then no
because because it's not a prediction
because you're putting all kinds of
conditions no it's not I'm not gonna bet
well I'm not gonna because you know that
is true how do we both know certain
things that's the point but we don't
know any we don't believe because now
that what is knowledge what is now
define now so that we so that we can get
on with it what what is knowledge yeah
define the word I mean you know you know
no don't make me example I wanna
definitely I need to figure know that
someone will dive they jump off the
building
barri when we call that knowing because
it's a word that's overused it's
Ordinary let me use it in ordinary you
have a feeling you believe you but it's
more than
it is justified true belief more than
why do you think that definition lasted
2,000 years it hasn't it has yeah but
it's the best it got because we all know
now you have an action of homework but I
think everyone who's listening can also
kind of feel what I'm saying where
everyone has this feeling no knowledge
that there's a difference between
believing and knowing that that's why I
tried to define the word I guess
different people don't you find word
belief in knowledge okay are those
conditionals that's the difference
because with the belief you're basically
going in not knowing what conditionals
there are and with no all you're saying
is if we remove all the very what does
that mean
it means that we know certain things
like if this domino hits the other one
but you know that then then the the onus
is on you to say which ones you're gonna
remove yeah and you remove a hundred and
you forgot the hundred and one it just
depends on how you word it and then you
forget the hundred and two now let's say
you you think all you have to say is if
my heart stops I die that goes through
everything no it does it because if I
die I die that's because your hearts
might stop for a second and stop again
any restarts yeah but that's what I'm
saying that's the difference between
belief and know with no you're you're
basically removing any weird
conditionals all these strongman things
that you keep bringing up these kind of
like devil's advocate League oh well you
don't really know the meteorite hit you
barring that weird stuff that's not
critically the chain of events that
would happen if no unforeseen things
happen that one foresee what does that
mean that means you didn't know
unforeseen means you didn't know but
because we believe it's it's it's in
practice because with belief we really
don't know all these unforeseen things
we don't know if a meteor will hit you
well you know what we're saying is if a
meteor doesn't hit you yeah but then you
gotta say if immediately if I lion
doesn't eat me if I if I if I don't see
it no no no why not okay
Leonard there's the number he wore which
you didn't cover no you come down to but
then but then you didn't know because
then you gotta tell me no no no because
then you gotta tell me which one
specifically you're gonna rule out and
and and then yeah you make a list and
then you forgot one you know I do I
think I was doing do it again what's
wrong and then there's a no-no and how
the offers how do you know you covered
them all because it doesn't happen what
it's radical that's my point is it's not
in practice it's theoretically speaking
if this economy theoretical because
knowledge is not the irradiance that's
my point
it's we have a dog and then and we say
if this dog doesn't get fed he will
starve at some point that is no belief
is okay we don't know it's um his wine
hold on let me finish with belief its in
practice so we don't know if this dog
you know might might get a meat in his
mouth or some weird [ __ ] you know if you
add some weird things happening in
between that's belief but no it's
basically barring any weird stuff if
this dog doesn't get that conditional
destroys again you gotta define the work
you gotta define the word you can't you
can't use the word know until you define
you but but everyone who's listening can
kind of understand my gist whereas maybe
they can't I sure you can because you'd
hear not smart enough but the people
listening know I'm talking about I don't
have the exact wording that takes like a
week of brainstorm okay what the actual
wording is but you know what I mean
the people listening or have that
intuition or where it's it's not about
prediction if it's theoretical no it's
about theoretically speaking if X Y Z
and you put all the conditions
it's like programming and when you're
programming something you literally put
all the conditions that you can think of
do you know the past can you know the
past does it make sense to use the word
know in terms of the past do I know that
Napoleon went to the water did do I know
that Cesar existed or lived or killed
something I guess
different type of no no oh it's a
different company because there's the
one that I was talking about was pattern
recognition know what you're talking
about memory you know well we use that
word oh I know that so they are
underwater but there we would need two
different words because those are very
two different concepts but that's how we
use the word you know yeah but hold on
but there's two very different concepts
only use those because there's I know
Napoleon went to Waterloo it's not Lee
you can replicate that it's not a
pattern in yes I'm I know I know there's
something happening well that's a
different type of no we need a different
word for I believe now because belief is
could also be either/or I can explain I
can describe I think I need for you to
come up see I'm saying the word no can
only be used in future tense I don't
think Oh in the future would you say how
do you prove that I know something if
not am i running no because what the
definition has to do with the future
it's not but then you'd say that you
can't use no I know that Napoleon was
wrong correct so you can't use that
correctly and I'm saying the word no can
only be used in a context dealing with
the future and as a new word and that's
why I'm saying that the definition of
the word now no or knowledge is that you
can predict the outcome of an experiment
a specific experiment without error and
that's impossible that's impossible
yeah that's why you can never do that
not even God can do that that is a
crappy definition yeah you can't use it
right correct and that's definition and
that's my that's why I'm saying the word
knowledge can never be used under those
Andy and then the the devil's advocate
or the skeptic as the Mona Swasey has
the owners of coming up with a
definition that we can use consistently
scientifically
rationally easily okay good now no but
seriously what is the point of defining
a word if you're not gonna use it I'm
trying to say this is what I'm trying to
say yeah this is what I'm trying to say
I'm saying that the word knowledge has
been used many times oh I know this I
know that we know this you know we
proven this or whatever you know and I'm
saying it's been overused misused
Plato says justified true belief a lot
of people say well if it's a belief so
knowledge is belief yes that's what it
is that's why knowledge has no meaning
whatsoever we can't use the word
knowledge for anything except an
ordinary speech no it's not because I
was saying the word without the sighs
definition I'm knowledge because you can
be used as I'm saying I'm saying the
precise definition of what we meant
throughout history
by the word now know or not be hold it
hold it let me pan I'm saying the
precise definition what people have been
referring to all these centuries is what
I'm saying
the way I define it and that's that we
can predict the outcome of an experiment
without error and that's impossible and
since it's impossible
it negates or nullifies the word now now
literally no well you presume to know
what they meant no it's not that I
presume if you look at history that's
what people refer to because you say how
do you know that for example the first
one how do you know that Napoleon went
to water and the guy will never be able
to answer that question for what he said
a minute ago we can't answer that
question so reckless all right so now we
can't use the word no like we always use
it like no in the past okay let's look
at the present can we know the present
well no it doesn't make too much sense
really you know what do you mean know in
the present tense
it's already past either it's a past or
to a future okay is the is the ever
present it's already it's already gone
yes the present works no but there is no
computer is always in front of president
president is exist the presents and I
know what's around me
we use that word we use the word and we
use it wrong because we think we know
what we're saying present is only
location that's all there is if there's
motion if there's action if you say I
know that this happened whatever then
you're not talking about the present
that's backwards isn't it no under
country motion is already the past it's
comparing the future against the past
yeah there's no such thing as the
present other than location which is the
only thing mother nature recognizes by
the way the location of every atom in
the universe
versus each other that's all I did it's
a cross-section of time and it's already
gone it's just one slice that's the
present because as soon as you think
about it's already you're already in the
future or or the other guy in the past
it's not about thinking about it well
whatever whatever you say like you know
you say thing about it well the present
is just okay go ahead yeah please what
is the present location you know it's
already ghost you're talking post
there's no no talking is already it's
you talking it's already too
[Laughter]
and it like drags on so you can it kind
of gives you the long present it's not
always this movie yeah it's a movie it's
not a movie so so it's not a Christmas
so the present yeah where does it begin
where does it end
no no I want to know how long how many
fit how many frames in the film but if
it's not any frame if there's any bring
your coat it's a it's a cross-section
okay because there are no frames that
you can cross section there's gotta be
one frame only for the present that's
human thinking Oh human sorry about that
we have to deal with frames that's the
best way that we have to replicate we
don't have to reality in on that level
you can't because again you're talking
about there's no such thing as the
present in the sense of motion soon as
you have motion you're talking about
past past and future education the
present is by definition motion that's
exactly not exactly the opposite why
does is the present is only location is
just location of every atom in the
universe across the whole time
no no as soon as you have motion you
have to to to location find it though
okay you got to define location you
think I came up with this one night and
I said oh I think I'm gonna come up with
no I came up with this after careful
reasoning I'm saying those gates you
know that the way people kind of I don't
care what people think into it no but
this is where you're gonna come into I
know it I come into a wall every day so
I understand that I'm just saying that
I'm defining location as you know the
the president's location it's a
cross-section of time it's just one
frame in the Universal movie if if you
can imagine such a thing which is you
know I used the term frozen universe god
freezes the universe he also freeze it
because if he moves and we're moving
with respect to him right but let's
assume he's out of it somehow he
magically freezes the
okay that's the present as soon as there
is a little bit of motion when Adam
moves in that direction everyone moved
with respect to that Adam and now we
have the future in the past because
because we know because that guy had to
have two locations with respect to the
rest of the matter but is this the
correct way of thinking about physics I
am physics not time it's the way to
think about physics physics - because
there's no such thing as freezing the
universe so no no except that chefs show
you think conceptually it's like you're
breaking the laws of physics by doing
that well you getting no no you're not
cheating because you're saying with the
frozen universe is one frame in the film
it's a cross-section of time any way you
want to visualize it but that's that's
what I mean what is location tell me
what location is define though though so
I don't have location oh that's how
mother nature season yeah there is
location no because motion is two or
more locations OD fine motion please
define motion then as location or three
frames in a movie because there are no
frames obviously in the universal okay
it's just this continuous now there's no
past abuse now I love that one continues
now good by the way everyone feels the
present there's no such thing as the
past is knows it because that's all
memory there's no such thing as a future
because that's just extrapolation of the
past in our minds past and future future
are all in our minds okay and freeze
framing the universes in our minds
okay so we have no knowledge because
what hasn't happened hasn't happened yet
yeah yeah because if knowledge has
nothing to do with the past it can only
be related to the future but now you're
telling me that you use the word now
okay I need a definition of location
motion and knowledge a three definition
home if I want to use those words okay
fine but if you don't use them then I'm
then I win because I said you can't
define knowledge and if you're not gonna
use now listen finds the word so I win
huh cuz I just don't use the word no
fine I'm just saying that right I'm just
saying the word knowledge cannot be used
because the word knowledge is only
having it right okay but no I'm
depending in a way we mean what we
always meant just to show that the word
cannot be used no that belongs to
ordinary speech because we cannot have
knowledge if so if you want to use it
lightning to show everyone right we
really are at least to put a flying
planet like okay if you don't agree with
my use of the word then please define it
so that so that you yourself can i think
it's very enlightening to define or
injure so I've tried it many times I've
tried defining not easy
morality holy crap morality is okay
define a word you really get to the root
of somebody because it webs out yeah
yeah because it's weighted usually worse
is you start off with okay what do we
mean by Bob and then you just put in the
word right what do we mean when I say
knowledge or by a or knowledge you know
what what types of architecture of
sentences can you build with the word
know okay I know my mom is my mom
I know Napoleon I went to Waterloo I
know if I do this there's no you know
that your bob is your Bob yeah told you
that I'm not sure or you know what the
condition contingencies are it's very
enlightening so when you tell someone
okay my definition of know is this
garbage
not the definition okay what is the
definition and then I mean the
conversation is there because now they
have to go away for a month to think of
the actual what they mean or what it
could mean what they could mean by Lord
no hmm and then it goes they go down
this rabbit hole is that what I mean by
knowing this then then they try to break
their own definition it's not easy by
the way your mom is not your mom's I
just wanted me to make sure that you
don't know that yeah anyway let's
continue we are in here on a tangent but
it's it's good to clarify some of these
things people think that defining some
of these words is just you know a breeze
it's not in fact that's why no one has
ever defined these words scientifically
rationally one and the other one people
use them and say well you know we need
two words that define words that he find
words and so we can never define any
word that's nonsense it gets even worse
with defining words because when you try
to define one word you necessarily have
to define another you know not
necessarily usually what I mean is you
try to break something done then you run
into another problem with a different
word you had and it's always a mess
inside a web I mean the way all your
words are defined for example they're
all defined in relation to each other so
that they all work with each other yeah
and that's important you have to define
you can't just because they won't
worried a foundation that's the point so
you can't really just define one word if
you want to yeah but there are words
going to talk about the words unifying
like exists object I mean it's hard to
talk about knowledge and oh so you talk
about you know location you can't talk
about location until you talk about yeah
know this they gotta be in a certain
order you go down these tangents and by
the time you you defined no twenty years
pass yeah yeah and so you got to be
careful in in definitions definitions
are so important people don't give them
any importance that's incredible
they've never realized at least that you
need some kind of foundation to do
physics and you know I think everybody
will agree with my golden principle
which I call which is that you need an
object to do physics
and you know people kind of say well
yeah like yeah okay so what and it's
like it's it's so weak so important it's
such an important principle now that's
not the problem the problem is people
don't give it any important that's not
the problem the problem is no no oh man
you got on that rabbit right that is a
rabbit hole whatever say see that first
number again
but my point here it's uh you know you
got to start with purpose suppose you
got to have a foundation and people
don't like to do that they say well
that's not physics that's not science
that's from grammar or ontology or
philosophy or whatever and so they
dismiss it and and then they use these
words and you say well what did you mean
by that and they say well you know what
I meant yeah I like the fighting words
because it really makes you grapple it's
like you have to write a thesis yeah
take a word and okay what is everything
related to this word what do we mean by
it what could we mean by it used this
word you just said it's a thesis on a
word what is the whole concept around
like love you always talk about love
when you bring up that concept okay what
do we mean by love yeah like let's let's
for the sake of of not even arguing it's
more like for the sake of science let's
put a fine point on love just for fun
let's see what let's see what we come on
so let's look at love okay what do we
mean by love what could we mean by love
what does love do what doesn't it do so
you can really like focus on the on the
word and be like oh so love is and then
basically you're doing is writing down
all the conditionals criteria
yeah criteria you write down all the
criteria yeah brain switch if fulfilled
that's basically what you knew you you
write the least amount of criteria
necessary to define necessary no
necessary for any concept or a word or
an object to be called this yeah yeah
and that's essentially what you got to
do you got to do a little brainstorming
you got to go through the list reject
what is not critical or not appropriate
or whatever and keep what is so that you
make sense of the word and only then can
you
coorporate that word in science and say
look now I have a rational definition I
can you consistently consistently
rationally scientifically now you know
you can use that word but if you know
people are just gonna loss over and say
well you know I don't deal with a
grammar I don't deal with definitions I
just want to do some science it doesn't
work that way excuse to delve into a
topic like one of these days we should
try and like live to define a word you
haven't defined before because that's a
lot of fun
now you take a word like love and we
just kind of banter back and forth yeah
or whatever I don't know height we just
take whatever word and we just kind of
go back and forth trying to write down
all the criteria yeah just just just to
show people how difficult it really is
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's really well
some concepts are even more difficult
probably if you take the or and or maybe
those no no but those are words right no
no no but what I'm saying but I'm saying
listen to me I'm just saying that the
finding some words like I don't know
object or whatever location might be a
million times easier than defining one
of these words because it is a word and
you say well what do you mean by more
well it's it's in it's in the dictionary
and that's wrong
okay we'll take it all right to the
grammar words don't be a bridge man
anytime because we've had that
discussion before I say you have to
define every word in your theory and you
say no really the only of the ones that
are critical yeah and then you always
use as a strong man bar eh yeah but
that's dumb because those are literally
any that aren't grammar words every word
is Ryan Allen what do you mean by
grammar and a words without could you
list them all please so that I make sure
there's probably about another action
I'm give me the list of words that we
don't define
not getting through to you but to my
listeners I listen tonight years I was
seriously to our listeners I think they
can understand the difference between a
grammar a word that we can remove and
we'd still understand the sentence let's
put it that way like hey I could or is
we're gonna understand the sentence if
we take or or and out you got to work on
that way he's more defiant but that's
the point this is the brainstorm to get
to the fine point of a definite all I'm
saying there are words that are much
more difficult to find an object but
really because you always say that you
don't have to define now are not nouns
but objects object yeah you point to
them like chair yeah you point to them
because you're just naming things if you
wanted to teach me you can't point to
invisible things right yeah you can't
point to concept I can't put the love
but I can point to chair I can put the
tree I can put the rug so that air falls
well yeah I mean all you can do in that
case is draw something and say you know
make a mock-up of what you're referring
to and show the et the Klingon who came
here and doesn't know your language
you're teaching him your language you
say well look I'm gonna teach you the
nouns first and and you can't point to
air because there's nothing there to see
but you say look I'm gonna draw it for
you this what I'm referring to and and
once you draw it you know you all the
little atoms and oxygen oh twos and
whatever and once he understands that
you say look I call this whole thing no
matter how you yeah you can point to
people kissing you can point to you know
but you can't point your lungs in love
really and you can't point the
space-time for sure because don't need
conditionals
no because object it represents itself
yeah I mean you point and you say three
and you just named something that's all
you did just gave a name to the object
that's in front of you so you don't have
to go beyond that you gotta say look
three wall floor you know you just point
and
that's it but we're talking about
concepts you always have to write down
the conditions that you call something
that concept yeah be concepts uh you
have to define and it gets a lot more
tricky yeah you get I mean I like I like
saying clearly the it's not defining
this more give conditions criteria yeah
this is right to you what is the
criteria to call it love what is the
criteria to call it jumping yeah what is
the criteria because you know some
things might be jumping something might
be others and then there's these weird
like halfway things jumping hopping is
coffee and different than jumping and
skipping you know you know they don't
have the word for balance they have the
word jump they just use the word jumping
ball jump for everything yeah so when
you throw the ball and it ricochets or
bounces off the floor it's jumping
oh it's jumpy okay you know they have
they have more words that they need in
addition they basically say you need you
need the the specific criteria like oh
no that's a hot that's not a jump right
balance that's not a jump and so you
need really specific conditions or
criteria to call it jump yeah because
you have like in English you got leap
hop skip jump all right is there any
difference well yeah yeah there's little
one like skipping is over something you
know but jumping could be up and down
but the other guy is you know it is like
over something and they're used for
different purposes and again it's very
nuanced but you know they're not exact
synonyms when you get down to I mean you
can say yeah they're all synonyms and if
you look them up they'll probably show
sort of synonyms but then what are you
gonna use right away yeah because it's
more accurate than the other word we
know what the accuracy is is what I
always bring up with the program you
know you have to define the words a
computer knows what you mean right right
in the computer
no does the rejects find it perfect
right the rejected
didn't use a computer understand this
that's the way it is it should work yeah
I understand it why doesn't the computer
understand right because there's some
unspoken thing there's some criteria
that you missed that you understand the
thing your computer rejects it or you
put one criteria too many and it's
calling hopper jump and say oh but
there's a difference between the two
it's like I put the same
I gave hop one criteria too many or the
wrong criteria now it's it's
mislabelling and when you and you know a
lot of these people who fight against
the grammar or semantic point of view
they should they should get fighting
with a computer yeah you know and then
they'll see why we need to define these
worth if the computer doesn't understand
it then don't tell me that you've
explained something or that you know or
whatever because if your computer
rejects it that's quite objective it
sounds silly though it sounds silly it's
48 deal over definitions but you don't
know the big deal it is so we take you
from random we don't know the big deal
that it is until I mean I challenge
anyone they use to define the word love
in a way that can't be corrupted by a
devil's advocate is that my job every
time I come at you basically my job is
basically to [ __ ] on whatever definition
came up with you can find the word
normally up I have an action item you
know he's he's a terrible guy created a
monster
anyways moving on here let's see we can
get on I was saying that you know again
we have this rational science and
rational science divided into rational
physics and rational philosophy
otherwise philosophy has no meaning it's
just a trivial you know that's an
opinion no no what I'm saying is illness
and this philosophy to referee if
anytime we're doing science we should
have a referee that lifts up the flag
every time you say something irrational
or use the word wrong I'm saying you
know philosophy has to explain something
if it's gonna be of any value otherwise
it's just philosophy like saying I'm a
philosopher oh that means you just do
thinking yeah I do think you okay so so
what he cares you know I mean fine
thinking right now we're back to that
yeah
no but if you say look philosophy has to
explain something now the guy's got to
break his brain and now he's got a
purpose for for philosophy which
includes purposes by the way and so what
happens we we've got these modern
definitions of philosophy which are no
good I'm saying I'm gonna define
philosophy in such a way that it has
some use or that it has some meaning and
for that I have to include it under
science and it does not include religion
it does not include opinions it doesn't
include irrational explains only
rational explanations related to what
the concepts purpose and reason that's
my take on it and I think people that
are rational should you know look at
that and say is this what we want the
word philosophy to mean now what happens
here why did I bring this up because I
wrote a an article a couple days ago and
it's in relation to Roger Penrose who
apparently said now that I put words in
his mouth this is what I read okay so
I'm not gonna take responsibility for
Penrose having said this but someone
says that Roger Penrose said this his
string theory is fashioned quantum
mechanic have quantum physics is faith
and cosmic inflation is fantasy and
Roger Penrose is a mathematician he
worked together with Stephen Hawking
recently died and they since you were
the guys who kick-started or
jump-started again
the black hole thingy and among the
theorems that at least Penrose proved
and mathematically is the what is it the
cosmic censorship which he says you know
there are no naked singularities
singularities come surrounded by an
event horizon and you can't have a
singularity out there you know a star
that collapsed a singularity without its
accompanying or encapsulating
event horizon and so he became an
essentially famous together with Stephen
Hawking for promoting black holes but
now he comes I guess in his old age and
he says you know straight theory is he
says fashion he meant nonsense quantum
physics is he said faith he meant
nonsense and cosmic inflation which is
Alan Guth saying he said fantasy he
meant nonsense they're all nonsense he's
saying essentially they're he's he's
being very kind of politically correct
he meant that all of these are nonsense
he doesn't he doesn't accept them
because there's no ounces again fashion
yeah but he's trivial staying
but he's trivializing them that's my
point he's saying it this is fashion
that's faith that's fantasy
he's meaning he's he's become an atheist
yeah he's important I'm saying he's the
guy who promoted black holes he's a
professor at Oxford University but he's
you know way yeah it's like Einstein
Einstein towards the end of his life he
became an atheist in general relativity
he never believed in quantum in his
entire life and then he came in yeah
yeah he wrote about he wrote letter
there to his friends and he says that he
essentially did not believe any longer
in the field concept which is underlies
everything today so he didn't believe in
that anymore
in his old age and he did say that he
was working at Princeton and he said you
know he's treated like a like an old
piece of furniture by his colleagues
nobody talks to him so he didn't die in
a very glorious way from a from a
intellectual point of view he died uh
you know with cobwebs under his arms in
a corner he had a job yeah but nobody
paid any attention and a lot of people
don't know that the people who think oh
I'm Stein Einstein oh you gotta keep in
mind i Stein died a very sorry
individual because he realized he hadn't
figured
how this universe works and like I said
he never believed in quantum and at the
end of his life he says you know
mathematical physics in its entirety is
it's nonsense because he he realized the
the directions this had taken and he
says you know that's that's not what I
really wanted that's I don't believe in
all this conservation yeah what he said
go to the weird is basically if this is
true then that's true that's true that's
true right right kind of weird and he
saw this in his colleagues officially
the new generation that's on one hand
but then uh you know Penrose you know
Penrose is over 70 years old and and he
may be reaching the same point where
he's so sick of what he's hearing out
there that he's he's becoming very
skeptical you know he now he deals with
conscious consciousness he doesn't deal
with quantum and he writes books about
consciousness now and he's trying to
relate consciousness to whatever they
came up with in physics which is it's
like he's going more into philosophy
because he it's like he doesn't know
because you don't have to have your feet
on the ground for that one is that the
other one is like you know we haven't
reached anything in physics so I'm gonna
move on and deal with something else you
know yeah and so and at the end of his
life so so that's why I think he's
writing this kind of stuff he's kind of
saying you know saying uh yeah I'm sick
of it I became an atheist and all this
myself I don't believe in all this it's
it's relevant because I put the article
and people you know came at me with
knives and you know with a robot no I
was saying look you know I was a little
facetious about it I'm saying you know
look here's uh
Penrose he's saying you know the one is
fantasy the other one is his faith etc
etc and I'm saying and he forgot to say
or he should have added you know that
all of mathematical physics is absolute
garbage all of it 120% of it yeah that's
what I put in there
so I put that in there and people for
some reason didn't like that okay then I
guess they I touched a nerve in there
and then they came at me with knives and
guns and and and what did they come up
with I said that you know none of this
is rational and people don't like that
word rational because they said well
tell me what is rational do you have a
definition I wrote a book on anybody and
it turns out that I did they find the
word rational I'm pointing their noses
over there and they didn't come back
most of them didn't come back some of
them came back but they didn't look at
the at the definition of rational so you
know they're they've got this this thing
where they just want to fight they just
want to argue but they don't have a
definite I'm saying okay do you find
rational and they don't have a
definition and so I do have what I think
is a an objective rational definition of
rational and I put four criteria there
you know and you should look at that
because you know it might help you
decide whether you think this is quite
objective and rational I'm saying you
know converting concepts into objects
and pretending to move them around
that's the main one and it's called
reification then you have you know using
undefined words or using them in
consistently throughout your
dissertation the theory doesn't follow
from the assumptions theory or the
explanation from the assumptions theory
from the hypothesis and I put a new one
in there which I think should be in
there maybe I should work on it a little
more it's to describe and claimed to
have explained you know I we've had a
lot of situations where people say oh
I've explained how a magnet works no
they haven't they described it and they
call that an explanation oh they tell
you I'm gonna tell you how a magnet
works and they're not telling you how
they're not giving you a mechanism
they're saying positive attracts
negative you turn it around you have
positive against positive and it rejects
it that's not an explanation
neither is an explanation saying oh the
electrons spin in the same direction
then you have this effect if they
spinning in opposite directions they
push each other away you still have not
explained the mechanism all you're doing
is giving a description you're saying
you know when they attract you have the
electron spinning in the same direction
that's all you're saying you're just
saying it in the opposite direction
you're saying oh you know I can explain
how Mannion attracts another see if the
electrons spin in in the same direction
clockwise both of them then you have
attraction that's a description you
haven't explained anything you haven't
explained how one bead turning on its
axis attracts the other one that's
spinning on its axis far away and so you
know again I'm gonna be including that
that fourth one in there the the
confused descriptions with explanation
that's an that's irrational also so
that's another criterion and and well I
guess we're gonna continue with this
tomorrow but essentially what I'm saying
is you know we got a problem with
understanding what rationality is we
have to get to the bottom of the word
irrational because these people don't
like that word it offends them but
unfortunately the definitions have to be
worked on it if you don't like my
definition hey you got only one recourse
and that's to define Durward yourself in
an objective way and you say well I
can't define it but I'm gonna use it and
I don't like you calling me irrational
or calling my theory irrational we got a
problem because you're just eluding you
know an objective criteria that I'm
putting up there okay with that we'll
see you tomorrow same time same station
see you then
bye bye